[Music]
foreign
that pain
[Music]
made me who I am
it's been a lifetime trying to right the
wrongs of the past
as if fighting crime would bring my
parents back
you actually did it
imagine what you've been
[Music]
I love you monkey you lost both parents
in one day
I went back in time to save my parents
instead
I completely broke the universe
and if you went back and changed the
past this world must die
future
do you know what the symbol stands for
means hope right
I will help you if I thought
you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
I have to undo what I did
these scars would have
make us who we are I'm about to go back
and fix them
don't let your tragedy Define you
thank you
no matter what we do
We're not gonna be able to fix this no
nobody died
you're strapped to your parachutes
you're in yours
foreign
I am honored to introduce to you the
creator of The Hunger Games themselves
Dean casca High bottom
I have summoned you all here for the
10th Annual reaping ceremony in which we
choose two children from each district
to fight to the death in The Hunger
Games from District 12 Lucy gray bear
[Music]
there has been a change this year as a
mentor Mr snow Your Role is to turn
these children into spectacles not
survivors
does my mentor do besides bring
my best to take care of you
carry me in that Arena
start by thinking I can actually win
I'm lucky flickerman first ever host of
The Hunger Games enjoy the show
[Music]
three two
enjoy the show
what happens in there
filled with the terror becoming prey
see how quickly we become predator
see how quickly civilization disappears
[Music]
it's a natural goodness
all
we can step across that line into evil
or not
you hear that boy
it's the sound of snow
falling
how wonderful that we all get to be here
for someone's final performance it's not
just about winning everything is about
winning
oh
it's the things we love most and destroy
us
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what I'll give you to decide your
faith
[Music]
what did you do back home
government work I'm retired
[Music]
because of these people I'm beginning to
understand real people and I'm starting
to believe
this is where I'm supposed to be
thank you
what happens here happens in many times
the mafia there's like cancer
no cue
I should say out of other people's
business
whatever it is you and your friends do
do it somewhere else you warning me I'm
preparing is that a Timex no it's a
[__] that's the median nerve but I'm
compressed
that's a level three you don't want it
to go to a level four
oh
[Music]
seem like a man who understands violence
like this place you can't take that from
me
it can take anything I want
police found multiple dead bodies on
that farm in Sicily did you kill him
[Music]
in seconds
do I look like a killer
[Music]
you know we don't really be there if
Roman wasn't driving Fort Knox on wheels
baby
it's a trap that's the bomb all right
dorks what are we blowing up what the
Vatican
wow you guys are going to hell
the great Dom Toretto if you never would
have gotten behind that wheel
I'd never be the man I am today and now
I am the man that's going to break your
family peace Peace by peace the devil's
coming
dummy I knew you would come for me well
how about we all just start shooting
each other
let's dig some Graves
you are not to be trusted are you in on
my Christmas list either
calvary's here
we need weapons and cars
Cannon cars do you like surprises I
adore them
I'd stay down if I was you you'll need
to hit me harder for that
the game's over down you lose
this is your last ride
then you might want to buckle up
everything
[Music]
centuries Our Kind has stayed hidden on
Earth
the darkness has found us again prime
this is about the fate of all living
things
Unicron is coming
[Music]
come on
back up Oh I thought we were boys
not a human here I'm nobody I ain't even
see nothing I'm not even seeing anything
right now
this is not our war
Optimus we must trust each other to
protect the home we all share
how big can this guy be uh he eats
planets so like way bigger than a planet
in the end
everything you cared for
will be consumed
maybe there's another way to save our
home
never faced anything like this
let them come
laughs
[Music]
yo Noah Take the Wheel
yeah baby
it's breathtaking
when you see sand here imagine water if
you dive in you can't reach the bottom
you dive in yes it's cold swimming I
don't I don't believe you
in the shadows of Iraqis lie many
secrets
the darkest of them all may remain
give house the treaties no father didn't
believe in Revenge
what if Paula treaties were still alive
thank you
have you ever had a dream about your
first ride
don't try to impress anyone
you're brave we don't know that
be simple
be direct
thank you
nothing fancy I understand
nothing fancy
[Music]
you will never lose people
we gave them something to hope for
May thy knife ship and shatter
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm gonna tell you something
I'm Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians
met a girl fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
came back in totaled dick oh please
he left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
things perfect
he just hated things the way they are
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to fight beside my friends
incinerate them
we're always searching for a family and
how we found each other
are you ready for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
and beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what
I noticed how black your eyes were they
were replaced by my father as a method
of torture he he picked a pretty set
who do you think the best driver is
probably Rory I would dust him in a
laugh
all you do is play video games with some
crazy dreams of racing cars Doug you're
the one that told us to always do
something we love
racing cars cost
look around it's not our world son
what is this it's a contest
the best Gran Turismo players in the
world
get a chance to compete in professional
racing dude this is real
I'm sorry I really think you're gonna
take a kid who plays video games in
their bedroom you're gonna strap them to
a 200 mile an hour rocket it'll tear
them to pieces
it's not gonna work the guys who race
are Elite athletes but I won't stop now
your kids are scrawny little gamer kids
well that's why you coming come on let's
go
must be a new experience for you moving
your legs
you puked on my lawn there's no turning
back man when you're in a race the
cockpit is going to be 140 degrees
Fahrenheit
key forces will be twice when an
astronaut experiences upon liftoff I
can't see anything
hey you get extra points for that in the
game Jesus Christ
Couchsurfing nerdy you sent me he is the
best one he made it
welcome to Team Nissan
what's next it's major leagues the other
drivers are going to hate
[Music]
you'll probably like heart of the game
it's called racing
there if you miss the line in the game
you reset you miss it on the track
you could die
I know this track
a bracelet a thousand times
that's what I'm talking about
but I won't stop now
[Music]
your days of fighting for the so-called
greater good
are over
[Music]
this is our chance
to control the truth
the concepts of right and wrong for
everyone for centuries to come
[Music]
you're fighting to save an ideal that
does
never did
you need to pick a side
foreign
[Music]
Captain Rambo
what the hell are you doing entering the
jump Point perimeter
I'm gonna get you some readings Fury
hello hello
[Applause]
[Music]
is this an Avengers test where's Captain
Rambo
[Music]
questions
hi we're looking for Kamala Khan
so our powers are entangled I can
manipulate light energy and you I could
totally show you
what again
hi where's our doctor Wherever You Are
thank you
[Music]
we're a team oh no no no we're not we're
not a team
[Music]
why am I here Roman I need you we're
gonna destroy that whole nuclear program
know the risk trust me
please be safe will you okay
oh my God
what sauce just came through the cia's
targets an Iranian nuclear facilities
and our covers blood we leave for 15
minutes
stretching point
to go home and I'll be with you
the distance is not the main issue
that's what's in between
any of them catch my guy we'll sell him
to the highest bidder there will be no
Sanctuary for you
raise your hands
do it before they get Trigger Happy
names
[Music]
tell me what's truly going on we cut
outs in an even bigger game this is my
life in your hands
no one is coming to rescue us
sorry
for everything
out
Charlie Brown
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm retiring well in that case what are
we drinking same for the goddaughter God
told me you found something on a train
during the war a dial that could change
the course of history why are you
chasing the thing that drove your father
crazy
he'll move please get out of here
sorry
Dr Jones get him
[Music]
yeah
Hitler made mistakes and with this I
will correct them all you stole it then
you stole it
and then I stole it it's called
capitalism
[Music]
[Applause]
first of all your seatbelt there might
be some tablets you've taken your
chances made your mistakes
and now a final Triumph
give him hell Indiana Jones
two times in my life we're seeing things
I've been to torture with Voodoo
been shot nine times
included once by your father
Rory
[Music]
and I've been looking for this
all my life
all right
excuse me Mr Reyes
you finished scraping the gum off that
lounger or what all right
everything right now feels so Out Of
Reach you always land on your feet bro
you're hymen
Jenny
God that's my life but do not open it
you went in to get us jobs and all you
brought back was the hamburger
okay I don't think it's a burger you
haven't looked what the hell is that
how did you get it to do that I think he
likes me
[Applause]
oh man
okay
[Applause]
re-entry systems ready
think what you want this ain't what you
want
what is going on
it's called this character it's some
kind of world destroying a weapons it's
designed to protect the toast
sometimes it does what you want and
sometimes it does it
I think I cut a bus in half
scared chose you
to me
glow you feel for your family
makes you weak
[Music]
the universe is sent you a gift and you
have to figure out what you're going to
do with it
whatever you can imagine
I can create
let's party
nice choice
it's like Batman stuff Batman's a
fascist
foreign
[Applause]
people burning
everything destroyed it was Athena she
was doing it
I was doing it my mom had that happen
I saw what you did in the ring
I knew that
you'd have to say it
what if I told you Sienna here is The
Reincarnation of the goddess Athena
and you are destined to become one of
her Guardian Knights
how does it feel to be a goddess
sometimes I feel like I'm a guest in my
own body
are you ready to start your training the
Pegasus Knight is Brave
humble and committed to protecting
Athena with his life
I heard you do that
and waits this is unlike any other
before
I must save the rest of us from her
you think I wanted any of this
powers of liability when she learns to
control it no living man will be able to
stop
you might want to buckle up
though you were the only night in town
[Music]
I was younger I joined
after I left I met a man named Caldwell
his clients wanted people dead
murderous dad breakfasts corrupt
officials
that's where I come in
[Music]
there she is I missed you oh God what
did they do to you nothing that's right
it's not fine every time you go away
Morgan it's a new job yeah I told you
I'm out it's not that simple it's six
separate contracts and each one pays a
million dollars tell me about it their
assassins more good like you
oh
not to kill me and each other factors
they were coming for you
whether you accepted or not
this is a game and if you want to live
you have to play try not to reduce the
splendid City to Rubble to make any
promises
foreign
[Music]
women to feel the consequences of what
we've done
all right
seven years ago one incredible story
blew up the internet when I was 22 I got
involved in the Russian mafia I was a
frat boy on a class trip this is Igor
he's here for your protection he's very
dangerous to talk to or hang out with
him all I want to do is hang out with
him I did not speak Russian
all I knew how to say was
it was literally the best summer of my
life we're robbing this guy
three years after those events
the story continues what is wrong with
this shirt
you help me not today brother not today
my dad showed up you paid money to see
my son tell his made-up story about
robbing a train for the million times
it's a true story it took about two
seconds before he started making me
mental look at
it he's a monster
are you the machine ma'am the party's
outside 23 years ago he was told the
only thing my father ever cared about
sorry this some sort of tick tock prank
I'm about to lose my [__] it's
definitely a prank clearly that's a fake
gun
or not they're coming with me back to
Russia
how fast are curious Peter something if
I'm on speed oh more drugs
take off that shirt and show those sobs
who you really are now you gotta party
with me
he's the machine
oh
fine I'll just gonna shoot him in the
leg
oh my God I'm going to freaking hell I
killed a man well
technically you killed several men
my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spider-Man and things are
going great oh yeah you're supposed to
be here all right whatever whatever wow
whatever so are you like a cow or a
Dalmatian I am the spot
it's not funny
don't don't do that
grades are pretty good A and AP Physics
that's my little man and a B in Spanish
what
okay miles
talking to you and I think you know it
[Music]
miles wanna get out of here oh win so
wait a minute there's an elite crew with
all the best spider people in it who's
the new guy this is unbelievable this is
the lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing with his
idea
what's the guy got to do to join this
spider team you can never be part of
this don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth
1999.99 come on go easy on the kid he
had a terrible teacher Peter miles you
have a baby
I'll take it from here
being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
ah send me home I can't do that I can do
both Spider-Man always always what about
Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of
us wouldn't be here
[Music]
you can't run forever dude I can't lose
one more friend
no idea what I'm doing
everyone
keeps telling me how my story is
supposed to go
I'm gonna do my own thing
stop Spiderman
[Music]
and then I looked at my
end let me guess he died
foreign
[Music]
okay thank you
[__] game come on man
[Music]
Ranger Alex diary British intelligence
we're here with the approval of your
state department
I've been sent to ask you to go into
Mexico and collect a prisoner
we believe he is planning a terrorist
event in London
is Ranger I think of like going up
against you
you knew they were gonna try to Spring
he's going to launch a dirty bomb help
me track him now you've already talked
to the major Everton
right
you're in the UK now protocol is
everything
you agree that that was quite Reckless
there's two tabs in this game
it was on a run
I was doing the hunt
who got their attention
unfortunately the favor is the Bold
show me them hands
good luck to your Ranger
Sean God
shall
perhaps you can help me I'm looking for
my son Roy and Quinn your son no wait
for somebody yeah it shouldn't be too
long for the luck I'm checking this out
either way
falling down get up against the wall
where are we going I need you to wait in
here can anyone please tell me where my
son is being kept stay quiet and we'll
get out of this together
my father wants a clean operation I
suggest you give me that phone call
I assure you he was here with an FBI
agent a vegetable drawing Senator boys
are complaining
easy first assignment got easy my ass
Ellis my partner's dead
take the back stairs down to the boiler
room what are you gonna do
skills from a past life we got some help
on the inside Captain Michelle Miller
Purple Heart three-time Gold Star let's
do everything we can to help that
Soldier
we are searching for Ryan and they are
not gonna stop
Ryan this family's going down whether
you like it or not an agreement she was
just going to hand Ryan back she's
working for the feds
thank you
once
where's my brother
bro you're late
let them know you're here
let the fights begin why watch out
Roy get up you know you cost me a lot of
money tonight you got 48 hours to make
this up to you
you haven't heard from Roy we don't go
this long without hearing from him get a
little worried sometimes he's a vagabond
fighting people for scrapbook
we're about to load uncut diamonds into
your truck and you know what'll happen
if this doesn't get the bar in the next
24 hours do you
you got a brother right the one with a
beautiful wife and the two daughters
what does Joe have to do with this I
need collateral
why not
[Music]
sound the alarm sound the alarm
I think this is
what did you get us into Roy 50 million
in diamonds
hello
the girls are gone the three of us are
getting my family back
Palazzo mansion that's what we're
looking set up sniper and cover us I'm
in position
[Music]
[Applause]
the question in my honor
[Music]
thank you